the 1990s brought a tidal wave of
sitcoms crashing onto television's
shores
some were amazing some were terrible but
all of them in time came to an
end these are the strangest most
interesting and most surprising stories
of 90s sitcom cancellations from the
fresh prince of bel air to fraser
freaks and geeks transcended its sitcom
status ultimately becoming one of the
defining teen shows of the 1990s
unfortunately much of its reputation is
posthumous it was cancelled after one
season
and never given another chance by nbc
high school is for learning
but it's also where you should be
learning how to socialize
the show debuted at 8pm on a saturday an
awful time for a new show
especially one aimed at teens freaks and
geeks then changed time slot pampering
any chance at building ratings the
producers created a website a rarity at
the time for tv shows to help fans keep
track of when it was on
but nbc refused to put the url on any
commercials
lest viewers gravitate towards the web
instead of tv
there were also tensions between the
producers and the network nbc wanted a
more positive show while the producers
wanted to keep things realistic
executive producer judd apatow became
particularly known for
viciously defending his show to any and
all network executives
in the end the show was canceled but its
legend has only grown
phenom a sitcom about a tennis prodigy
and her family lasted one season
and has largely been forgotten the show
had a lot going for it at the start
and perhaps more importantly it had a
great time slot right after the mega hit
full house so why was it cancelled
depends on whether you ask
abc or the producers abc implied it was
cancelled because it underperformed
reviews indicated a lack of direction
for the show but this was still a shock
to fans
phenom creator and executive producer
dick lesuchi was also surprised the show
was axed
he claimed that even though their own
metrics showed good ratings
abc told them that their numbers didn't
match many saw this as code for a
network
looking for an excuse to cut a show
third rock from the sun followed a group
of aliens masquerading as an upper
middle class american family
studying human habits and reporting back
it was
if you'll excuse the space pun a far-out
show that dabbled in everything from
witty word play to slapstick
it had a great cast including john
lithgow and kristen johnson
and introduced the world to joseph
gordon levitt the show was off-kilter
enough to have dedicated fans
but it had a hard time maintaining
casual viewership thanks to a frequently
changing time slot the network didn't
believe in third rock in spite of its
longevity
as such the finale of season six was
designed as a series finale and the
creative team signed on for different
projects
correctly suspecting the show was done
the cast ultimately accused the network
of having mishandled the series
will smith's career trajectory from
rapper to living with his auntie and
uncle in bel
air to the world's biggest movie star is
a strange arc starting as the fresh
prince with dj jazzy jeff in the 1980s
smith got rich from his music
only to blow all his money on an
unsustainable lifestyle
after getting in trouble with the irs he
signed on to star in a sitcom largely
because he needed the money
luckily for him the fresh prince of bel
air went on to become one of the most
memorable sitcoms of the 90s
running the gamut on topics from normal
teen issues to somber dives into racial
discrimination
it was such a hit that it never left its
8 p.m monday time slot during its entire
run
by the end of the series smith had
become a mega star in addition to the
leading role
on fresh prince he also had six degrees
of separation and bad boys under his
belt
and he was set to star in a movie you
may have heard of called independence
day
smith loved his castmates but recognized
the show as limiting and knew it was
time to move on
he had something bigger in mind goodbye
will bye-bye
the fresh prince was cancelled largely
because smith was ready to move on to
the big screen full time
few sitcoms come longer running and
better loved than frasier
starring kelsey grammer as radio
psychologist fraser crane
the show went through almost the
entirety of the 90s and beyond
originally a spin-off of cheers fraser
stuck around a season longer than its
predecessor
but why would such a long-running and
successful sitcom get cancelled part of
it was a ratings dip yes
but the larger part was unsustainable
production costs
long-running shows often see higher
production costs given that actors
salaries tend to rise and more care is
put into the show itself
by the end of the final season each
episode of frasier cost over five
million dollars to make
1.6 million dollars of which was
grammar's salary
he implied he'd be interested in the
12th season and might take a pay cut
but an nbc spokesperson said the network
just couldn't see the numbers working
so the show's writers decided to end
things on a high note
thank you frasier for
well you know
strangers with candy was one of the most
bizarre and acclaimed comedy shows of
the late 90s
starring amy sedaris as jerry blank and
featuring comedy icons stephen colbert
and paul danello the show was a hit on
comedy central
it ran for 30 episodes over three
seasons in 1999 and 2000.
its weird twisted morals alone make for
some of the best comedy of its era
even though it's mostly a cult hit as
such strangers with candy often makes
lists of shows that were cancelled too
soon
here's the catch though according to
sedaris the show was technically never
cancelled
in that era most comedy central shows
only lasted three seasons
and the strangers with candy team
operated under the assumption that
they'd be no different
sedaris later noted that the final
episode of the series was simply written
assuming it would be the last
and it just worked out that way martin
was one of the highest rated sitcoms
during fox's rise in the early 90s by
the end of the show's run it was still
the third most watched show among black
viewers
it was a hit however you slice it and
still does well in syndication when it
ended
somewhat abruptly after five seasons
star martin lawrence said it was because
he felt it was just time to move on
this sounded plausible enough at the
time thanks to lawrence's budding movie
stardom
of course even in the pre-twitter days
lawrence was enough of a public
presence that most people suspected
differently his erratic behavior was
making headlines even before
co-star tisha campbell filed a sexual
harassment lawsuit against him after she
quit the show
the lawsuit was settled and campbell
only appeared in the series finale on
the condition that she didn't have to be
on set with lawrence
lawrence told gq magazine in january
2020 that he regretted a lot of his
behavior in the 90s he also openly
acknowledged for the first time that he
walked away from martin because of the
lawsuit
martin and campbell are reportedly on
good terms as of late so there's at
least a happy ending
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one